Switzerland in a few weeks time
the people who
hundred thousand too bad
hold on the government tries to move
straight down the weeks ago observer
beingness and so the government is never
used to down said no we're only
prosecute the people but oppress the
women so make them wear a burka because
the opposition says I know these people
be gone to ground they're gonna be the
big kept under house arrest so the
interesting to see which way that black
TV shows we should have whether it is
nutrients whatever your issue is you
know the honest thing we can tell people
what till we are but why not we're just
telling them one thing that they can't
we are in the complete coupling whether
it's a miracle one thing it's not
Western culture when I look at you I can
I can look at your eyes and I can see
with your anger you can see to your
facial expression we were sitting in a
world-known store in Oxford streets at
the moment taping this conversation and
as I walked in here today there are I've
seen 10 women conceding conversation
with her what her reaction is she is
basically shutting herself up in society
she's sticking her middle finger up
saying I don't want to engage with you I
might live in this country but I don't
worry engage with you John easel or you
whoever you are I am shutting myself
and that's wrong that's not part of our
culture it's a closed door and Shaklee
be mouthing anything that you think that
vodka should give us in